blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman all right let's start today with
another
bizarre
uh step
that anti-vaxxers are willing to take
uh despite not wanting to just go and
get the vaccine which is a known
quantity
there are now people
snorting and gargling iodine
presumably to fight covet 19. this is a
really bad idea and as is the case with
with many of these things i have no
problem telling you
what the kernel of a scientific basis is
for where this came from and i'll tell
you that in a moment here's an article
from men's health which says iodine was
once a popular treatment for your
typical cut and scratch and now anti-vax
circles are claiming that gargling or
snorting it works as a preventive for
covet 19. povidone iodine known
commercially as betadine is typically
used on the skin as a first aid
treatment or a disinfectant for surgery
prep remember in school you would get a
cut you'd go to the nurse's office they
would put that
iodine yellow the yellow stuff on it it
would sting and you know and then you
would go back to class
typically the brand has also introduced
a 0.5 mouth rinse meant to treat a mild
sore throat
not to prevent covid on september 8 a
twitter user claiming to be an er doctor
tweeted and we will show you the tweet
don't get covered
prophylaxis is not that hard
also nasal spray with a couple of drops
betadine in it and gargle with original
listerine so you see here
there are a bunch of things in the
picture uh which i will describe there's
vitamin c there's melatonin
there is uh i don't know what that thing
in the middle is zinc vitamin d and then
adds nasal spray with betadine and
gargle with original listerine
unfortunately
this is a disinfectant
as william schaffner doctor professor of
preventive medicine at vanderbilt says
its use has slowed down because even on
scratches and cuts its effectiveness has
been debated there's no data this would
be effective for kovid
avreo health the makers of betadine has
also intervened in online conversations
saying betadine antiseptic sore throat
gargle is only for temporary relief of
occasional sore throat it has not been
demonstrated to be effective for the
treatment or prevention of covid19 or
other viruses so there's a few things to
talk about here first of all
there are some studies that have been
done
which say that
if you uh
use and and it is it's very speculative
data but if you use
um uh
let me see how the right way to apply
this is in a petri dish
if you use something like an iodine
solution
it seems to reduce the viral
uh
level of viral particles
but again this is based on in vitro
studies and only for a little bit of
time so
most optimistically what we could say
right now would be
if you put some of this stuff in your
throat and you have some virus particles
in your throat but really the virus is
in the lungs right
it's possible possible that
in in some brief sense
it would reduce the number of viral
particles in the mouth and throat
but because it's in the lungs if the
infection is in the lungs then within a
very short time those viral particles
are going to reappear in the throat
uh what's going on here
is that it's very similar to what
happened with hydroxychloroquine and
ivermectin
iodine is just
around it's cheap okay it's widely
available everywhere so
much like with hydroxychloroquine or
ivermectin it's logical that we would
say
does any of the cheap stuff we already
have and that's plentiful
work for covid and sometimes you'll
stumble across a false efficacy signal
as we saw earlier with
hydroxychloroquine you might stumble
across some in in vitro study or
something like that you know the the
the new thing when i go to my dentist's
office is they have me rinse with with
something
and
all it you know my dentist says it it
seems as though just at a very micro
level
it's possible this might kill some virus
particles in your throat right now but
if you're infected and it's in the lungs
and you're breathing it
the the throat and the mouth are going
to refill with it very very quickly so
the big picture story here is how are
people that are insanely skeptical of
things from verified sources about known
quantities like the vaccine
willing to accept what random people on
twitter say
and just going and doing it that's a
real problem that's a real crisis
and it's a crisis of education it's a
crisis of media literacy but in the
meantime
don't snort and or gargle iodine
solution not something you want to be
doing
i want to follow up about this bigger
story through covid that we're seeing of
conservative radio hosts anti-mask
advocate radio hosts anti-vaxx radio
hosts
dying of covid after bashing vaccines
business insider now reports
at least
seven conservative radio hosts and high
profile anti-mass anti-vax advocates
have died from covid in recent weeks
radio hosts bob enyart dick farrell phil
valentine and mark bernier as well as
former cia officer and conspiracy
theorist robert david steele
anti-master caleb wallace and south
carolina republican conservative leader
presley stutz
shared conspiracy theories about
theories about vaccines before catching
covid
they told supporters misinformation
about the virus they held rallies in
opposition to mask mandates as coveted
cases continue to surge nearly all of
the deaths are among the unvaccinated
and misinformation remains widespread
remember all of these stories we talked
about bob enyart refused to get
vaccinated before dying of covid he had
a show called real science radio he died
monday
um
dick farrell from florida radio host
advocated against the vaccine on
facebook before his death
said the vaccines were bogus said fauci
was a power tripping lying freak he died
of covet
uh phil valentine we covered extensively
who actually became a vaccine advocate
after being hospitalized he didn't make
it phil valentine died
mark bernier we covered another florida
right-wing radio host said on air he was
against vaccines i'm not taking it are
you kidding me mr anti-vaxx jeepers
he died of covet
former cia officer robert david steele
spread covet denial conspiracies
uh throughout the pandemic
he died from covid
over the it looks like the last weekend
in august
this is not fun it's not funny it's it's
sad
and uh it's happening to people that
listen to these folks as well caleb
wallace anti-massacre who protested
covid's safety measures spent a month in
the hospital only 30 years old and died
called covid tyranny called lockdowns
and masks covet tyranny
uh
by the way another important detail he
started showing symptoms in july
and treated himself with ivermectin
vitamin c zinc aspirin and an inhaler
none of those things shown to actually
work for covet
pressly stutz
64 year old south carolina conservative
group leader died after making fun of
masks
chair of the greenville tea party
made false statements about the virus
downplayed the importance of mask
wearing
so listen in terms of hierarchy and
reach
and audience
these are relatively low level radio
people right i mean they were they seem
to have been true believers
they've now paid a price
the larger audience people you know
hannity tucker
laura ingram glenn beck people like that
um
they strike me more as being con artists
i think particularly given the
revelations that fox news's vaccination
and testing program is even stricter
than the one outlined by joe biden and
yet tucker and laura they keep working
there
my sense is that the fox people aren't
really true believers they are grifters
these guys really seemed to be true
believers and you even saw them change
some of them like phil valentine when it
started getting really really bad
um unfortunately even these deaths may
not convince people of stuff if you go
on the right-wing enclaves online
you will see people writing these guys
were murdered
because they spoke out against the
vaccine
it's an unfalsifiable claim right well
it looks like if you're unvaccinated
you're more at risk and look now these
people died no no no no they were killed
this the conspiracy goes because they
spoke out against the vaccine
there is no convincing a lot of these
people
but hopefully these deaths are not
completely in vain they are senseless
but they are hopefully not completely in
vain in that some people will have been
convinced to get vaccinated as a result
i don't know if that's the case let me
know your thoughts you can find me on
twitter at deepakman
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
welcome back to the show remember that
we are primarily funded by individual
members through the david pakman show
membership program you can sign up
really you it's not other people i'm
really talking to you you can sign up at
joinpacman.com you can use the coupon
code better21 to get a discount off of
the membership and of course you will
get instant access to the bonus show
access to commercial free audio and
video streams of the david pakman show
and so many other great things
let's hear from people in the audience
it's a novel concept i know
but let's hear from people in the
audience we do this via discord you can
find the discord at davidpakman.com
slash discord conveniently enough
let's start today with tom from new
jersey tom you are on the air what's on
your mind
hey david can you hear me i can
hey um this is my first time calling
i've been uh
uh listening to you since 2016 so thank
you um yeah um i just started a new
semester which is uh my first time in
person in a classroom in two years yep
uh yet yesterday i had a professor tell
us about for an hour why she was a
vaccine hesitant
and um she was talking about how the cdc
said people who
had coveted shouldn't get the vaccine my
question is like what should we do about
like people who are professionals who
are telling like students and such they
shouldn't get the vaccine beautiful so
first of all what she is saying is
untrue the the um
cdc has not told
people who have been sick with covid not
to get the vaccine i do believe there at
one point was a requirement
that you wait some number of days after
recovering before getting the vaccine
uh but i am not aware of anything about
if you've if you've been if you've had
covet don't get vaccinated that's number
one number two what clap what type of
class is this what's the subject matter
of the class
you'll never believe but it's a health
psychology class okay so it is not a
class on epidemiology and it doesn't
seem like the the woman's or virology it
doesn't seem that the professor's of
views on vaccination are relevant so
what i would do
is i would go to the department chair
i would go to the provost
i would let everybody know director of
is this an undergraduate class
yeah director of undergraduate studies
whatever i would let everybody know
uh i am filing a complaint because the
teacher in a health psychology class
spent an hour ranting about her vaccine
hesitancy
including spreading
you know incorrect statements uh
contradictory to the cdc
um i i would just report it and let the
university handle it
all right thanks pacman i was incredibly
frustrated yesterday listening to that
it's horrible it's absolutely crazy and
uh it's i mean listen it's probably
happening at a lot of different places
is the reality
yeah yeah you think you'll do it you'll
you'll report it
yeah i'm planning to okay good please
follow let us know what happens okay
all right thank you i'll call back thank
you tom from new jersey uh yeah let's
get that going we we've got to deal with
that that just can't be allowed it's uh
it's a real it's a real problem
all right let's go next to
um
let's go to miguel from el paso texas
miguel you're on the air
hi can you hear me yes i can
okay perfect uh hi david uh so i had a
question i have two questions uh in fact
um
i wanted to uh know whether you'd be
interested in
um in interviewing someone from um or
reaching out to uh the sunrise movement
do you know about the sunrise movement i
i'm familiar with the i remember the
name of the organization are they sort
of a uh like releasing public records
and documents about things type group
not really they're a um
uh they're like uh an organized movement
uh made up of young individuals uh like
me
uh who um are trying to who do activism
for um
mostly uh environmental causes okay um
so they have plenty of chapters like all
around the united states and their main
goal is uh to
spread uh like the basis of the green
new deal uh to
uh you know not just in a uh national uh
white uh sense but also like in local uh
in their local chapters see what they
got to bring uh green new deal proposals
to
um
to local um
yes to local areas that it sounds like
great work as an interview on the show
it would be what we call a dud
unfortunately those types of interviews
don't do well they'll get 2 000 views
and people will write to me and sell
david that was that really was was not a
good interview for the show so i love
what you're describing that the
organization is doing
i'm not going to you know kind of blow
smoke though it's probably not an
interview for this particular show
that's okay i understand i just i was
just thinking like um you know there's
plenty of people out there young people
like me who don't want to do something
about climate change yeah and they don't
know exactly where to go and you know
maybe an interview uh with a
representative or someone um
of that uh
uh rapport could you know bring light to
that maybe they can go somewhere um that
you know they can make some change um
but that's okay i understand fully if uh
it's your show you know
you do what's best for you good um my
second question is not as serious um
so
uh given that you're
[Music]
a native from argentina am i correcting
that assessment that's an absolutely
correct assessment yeah
okay perfect so uh i wanted to know what
your opinion is on a famous popular band
uh soda stereo love it um love them yeah
do you have a do you have a favorite
record that you would recommend as a
beginner or no no i don't i'm not
familiar enough with the discography to
be able to recommend specific records
but no no right before the pandemic i
went to a soda stereo cover band
um and no no great great band of many
great argentinian bands
alrighty perfect i was just curious
about that thank you so much david i
really appreciate it all right thank you
very much appreciate the call very nice
guy great to hear from people
let's go next to
let's try fred from germany fred from
germany you're on the air
hello can you hear me dave yes i can
oh great i'm a big fan of your show i've
been uh
oh i'm i'm a little nervous but i've
been um i've been a listener for about a
year oh great
um
i want to ask a question about about um
yeah i have an economic question
um
and you talked a lot about um
the debt and deficit yes
um and i'd like to know
um you just interviewed someone who
wrote a book about a post-growth
economy
and my question about that would be
um if you are in favor
of sort of post-capitalist post-growth
ideas and i don't say that you are
that's like a general you
um shouldn't you be worried about
debt and deficit
in the way that um
if you're increasing the debt or the
deficit and too high magnitude you're
sort of creating um a need for more
economic growth because if you um if if
the debt grows much faster
than the economy then um
that's bad right
yeah so you this really would be a
question for someone who is actually
like a post-growther because that i'm i
don't i don't know that i'm a
post-growther i think there is obviously
some physical limit to the resources of
the planet and at some point that will
become a factor but
you're there's really two points of view
on your question right one is well if we
want to go to post growth part of the
reason we need growth is because we can
continually have more debt so we need
the growth in order to pay for the debt
that would be one view so that would be
the more debt there is the more the
longer we're locked into needing the
growth that's one view but there's
another view as well
and the other view would be
if eventually this is all a house of
cards that will implode because we will
reach the limit of resources for the
country for the planet rather
then these
financial ledgers on which we have debt
are sort of irrelevant either we get to
a point where it doesn't matter
or the planet collapses and therefore
who cares about dead in deficit so i
don't you know it would be more of a
question for somebody who's really an
ideologue in that i don't say it in a in
a negative way but an ideologist in that
space but it seems to me you could
really make the argument on both sides
of that question
okay
thanks for your answer and uh yeah thank
you for answering my question my
pleasure thanks fred
all right fred from germany
very specific question i like it
let's go next to frumpus from chicago
frumpus you are on the air
hold on david
oh take your time all right hello can
you hear me okay yes i can
okay so i've been having cumbersome
oh and you're cut you're cutting out
already so we had the first cutout so
let's see if we can get to the
uh let's see if you can start over
you're have you cut out you're having
conversations
okay yeah i've been having conversations
with um like some cynical republicans
about
this talk about
democrats wanna want to raise taxes on
the rich and all this
and um
the cynicism comes from
uh these republicans will respond to me
and say well why would these politicians
vote to raise taxes on themselves and um
i kind of struggle to respond to that
because i'm sure there's examples of
times they've done it in the past
um but i just don't know how to respond
to that type of cynical attitude towards
this these bills so there's a couple
there's a couple different things couple
different things first of all
the the taxes so let's see how to break
this down in pieces first of all the tax
increases that are being proposed
are actually for people whose salaries
are higher than that of most of our
elected officials you know members of
the house and senate make a hundred and
seventy five thousand dollars a year i
think if you're in leadership it's more
like 215 or something like that biden is
talking about this is gonna hit people
uh making over four hundred and fifty
thousand dollars as a couple or four
hundred thousand individually or
whatever the case may be now the counter
might be well a lot of these people have
more income than that because they also
have whatever business they had before
entering the house or senate or they
have a spouse like nancy pelosi's spouse
makes a lot of money all of this sort of
stuff so so the first part is it's not
always the case that these things would
hit them number one number two
why would an elected official do
something that doesn't benefit them
financially well if they actually cared
more about what was good for the country
and what their constituents want it is
after all representative democracy we
don't elect these people to do what's
good for them we elect them to do what's
good for us and to represent our views
so it's an insanely
uh
it's not even cynical but it's the whole
point here is they're being elected to
do the will of the people that's why
they might pass a bill that would
increase their own taxes and if they're
not willing to do it they should be
removed from their positions
right i agree um and then just one
one more comment on that thing that you
um the
raising taxes bill that you just
referenced yes that includes like
investment income and capital gains and
such or no well my understanding is that
it is talking about earned income like
wages so when it talks about five
million dollar earners or whatever my
understanding is that's not talking
about capital gains
a little bit of the problem honestly
frumpus is that a lot of this stuff has
not yet we've not yet seen like pen to
paper
and exactly the way it's all going to
work it's just kind of bullet points and
and that's why i'm keeping my analysis
macro economic in general until we
actually know exactly how all these
things are going to be set up
okay david thank you for your comments
take care my pleasure all right frumpus
from chicago very much appreciate that
let's uh let's speak next
to zach from toronto canada zach you're
on the air
hey david uh can you hear me yes i can
i was uh i was curious because i uh i
saw a video on
you talking about socialism
i was curious of your reasoning of why
you think
the means of production
should be privately owned rather than uh
publicly owned well i so i i approach it
a different way
um okay
my approach would be
um
why would the means of production which
might be
built by an individual
paid for by an individual
insured by an individual
financed by an individual why should
ownership be taken away
and either made
a
societal or in a communistic sense
state-owned why why would we do that
what would be the justification
from taking it away from the individual
that built it
huh okay i um
i guess i never thought about it from
like
the latter perspective
well i mean apply it to anything right
so so you're you're sort of like
for me
the action that would be required to be
justified would be
why would why would we be allowed to
change the ownership structure of
someone that's something that someone
built if you you know you go to school
and you learn plumbing for example
and then you go and you buy all the
plumbing equipment you might take out a
loan to buy that plumbing equipment and
you're a plumber for a bunch of time and
then at a certain point you get big
enough where you start hiring apprentice
plumbers and all these different things
so it's it's your business you own the
equipment you hire the employees what
would be the justification for saying
okay now the business is no longer yours
now it belongs to all of your employees
or it belongs to the state what would be
the justification for that
um
[Music]
i uh i'm not sure
actually i um
i'm personally not a socialist but i'm
interested in
socialist theory and i was just i was
curious of
why you personally weren't a socialist
but i mean
that yeah that does make sense so i have
a ton more broadly i have a ton of
videos about why i'm not a socialist but
to answer that specific question
it's because i don't think there's any
justification for it
okay great thanks david i appreciate
hearing your uh perspective i appreciate
the question thank you so much for
calling in
let's go next to jake from chicago jake
from chicago you're on the air
jake from chicago you were on the air
fellow can you hear me david yes i can
hey david i'm a long time listener i'm
currently a student at the university of
alabama and one recent trend among these
southern college football games has been
the f joe biden chance hearing these
lunatics completely make ironic keep
politics out of sports and then feel the
need to disrupt the environment of the
game how do we approach dealing with
these kinds of people
well approach in what sense you mean
what should be done at the game when the
chant breaks out or more generally
just in general speaking like how can we
just like
change it so that these people aren't
completely hypocritical with what they
say i'm not aware of any way to the
hypocrisy has actually we've been
covering the hypocrisy for more than a
decade on the show
and the hypocrisy has only gotten worse
and worse my body my choice
uh when it comes to
the vaccine but not when it comes to
abortion um no debt and deficit or bad
except when it's a republican president
don't regulate businesses except when
they want to require vaccinations so i
think it's a lost cause on the hypocrisy
i think we've just got to figure out a
way to not be annoyed with them um and
i've i've been reading about the chants
at the football games like wow big
surprise a football audience in the
south of the united states doesn't look
like joe biden it's got to me it's kind
of like it's not really big news you
know
yeah i remember when two years ago when
trump came to the alabama versus lsu
game i've never heard a louder stadium
in my life it was
just crazy these people going absolutely
nuts for this man yep well that is the
south and they uh tend to vote
republican so not really surprising but
you know quite frankly i'd be avoiding
large sporting events at this point in
time and then i i'm both skipping the
covid risk as well as the by anti-biden
chance
yeah that's fair i i enjoy going to
games but i'm also messed up with the
game so i'm trying everything i can to
mitigate but i completely understand
about knockout oh that's interesting how
how many other are are people tending to
wear masks it's not no nobody nobody has
masks on there our school does have a
mask mandate yeah but in outdoor areas
people don't really follow it as much uh
right okay yeah and outdoor it is less
uh less less important i would agree all
right well stay safe down there jake
well thank you thank you
there is jake let's take a quick break
if you're holding to talk to me don't
hang up
uh because we're going right back to the
phones momentarily
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
all right let's hear from a few more of
you
in the audience we take calls these days
via discord you can find the david
pakman show discord at davidpakman.com
discord let's go next to ashley from
florida ashley you were on the air
hi david um i'm a big fan of yours i
listen to you all the time thank you
thanks for taking my call pleasure i am
in florida and right now what we're
dealing with
are no masks in schools
we have people fighting against crt
and
um i recently went to one of our school
board meetings trying to advocate for
masks in schools
um
there's no the state has not taken
funding
or education for virtual options
from the federal government right so
i feel really out of luck with my kids
i'm just wondering
um with the recent events with the proud
boys being at the meetings in california
yesterday well not the meetings but the
um at the new sum rally yeah
yeah
they're also here in our schools and our
in our um
board meetings and i would say so let me
let me see if i can understand that
actually these are
parents who are also proud boys or these
are just random proud boys going to the
to school board meetings to complain
about masks
they're parents that are proud boys oh
wow there are parents that are proud
boys in the school district
yes and are they making a big commotion
at the meetings
no
there were a lot of police at the one we
were at which i know
it seems like sometimes they're one and
the same but because i think of the
extra police presence they had
there wasn't a fight but the county
north of me and lee they had a fight
recently you did a story on them yeah
listen i don't know i'm gonna be really
honest i was just talking to friends
who have kids right now
recently and i was saying
if throughout this pandemic i had had
children and had to figure out daycare
schooling they can't be vaccinated some
places don't want them to wear masks
i don't know what i would have done it
seems impossibly difficult like i i just
can't even imagine it's one of the worst
aspects of this pandemic does it occur
to you to pull the kids from school is
that even possible
not that i'm recommending it not that
i'm recommending it
yeah i have pulled from school but
there's some parents
who even if they wanted to they can't
because
there's no funding the state refused
federal funding for virtual options so
they didn't really give parents a choice
on this end of things right and some
people are saying i'm going to home
school
but that's number one arguably not so
good socially for the kids and number
two a lot of parents work so they can't
be homeschooling
right
and i think everybody deserves to be
able to have a public education and be
safe absolutely absolutely yeah i know i
i can't i can't even imagine it's um
i mean what what
what's the hope just that
we eventually get past the pandemic i
mean is there really any solution while
the pandemic is going on it seems like
it's becoming a lost cause in some of
these counties i know that's why i was
calling you yeah to see if you had any
answers do you have it i'm like are you
is there any action you're thinking of
taking let me put it that way
yeah we have
we're trying to organize but i think
we're really outnumbered here
it's difficult
yeah yeah well listen ashley i wish i
had specific advice for you i don't
because it's a tough situation
but i we're with you and keep us posted
about what goes on down there
okay thanks david all right thanks
ashley ashley from florida
not a good situation guys not a good
situation at all
let's speak next to
emily emily you are on the air
and emily disappeared
let's go next to justin from new york
justin you're on the air
hello
hello
oh can you hear me or
yes i can
okay hey david how are you first time
first time a caller long time listener
thank you
my mom um i have a question though like
um because i always ask is that like
them
because you don't have like president
anti-masking facts and everything i have
so my friends are pro-vaccination but i
always asked everybody to get a good
answer for is that like
what's the end goal like
because if you're not going to get the
vaccination you're probably going to get
covert so your angle just to get covered
and
survive yeah
yeah that's it that that's that's their
that's basically their view i mean have
you asked them what do they say when you
ask them
they say because they literally try to
they say like oh i have it in the system
or oh i'm scared of the shot like
like
like
i got well i got the johnson one and
like that
it hurt yeah but the thing is though
it's like
it's just something you you
like i always try to feel like though i
don't know if you have any like um
i don't wanna
censor like quit being you know a b word
about it and just take it
yeah when people
i have a question when you say that you
got the vaccine and it hurt are you
talking about the moment they inject you
it hurts like the little prick from the
needle hurts or are you talking about
like later you had arm pain or whatever
yeah both you know like like the moment
they don't like it's like as a chakra
you're fine but then after that like i
had arm pain and i had two fevers but
after
after the vaccination
but
after that like after that done day i
was just fine i was just like i'm just
sore yeah like i get that there's
there's a fear of needles
and that's a specific thing but when
people say
getting the shot hurts i mean it's
literally one second i i they they put
the shot in
is maybe it's three seconds that part i
don't get like i get the fear of needles
that some people have that's a widely
known thing
i get
not wanting to feel sick for a few hours
or a day or two or whatever flu like but
the actual pain of the shot i don't get
because it's it's under five seconds you
know it's that part is strange to me
that that would make someone not get
vaccinated
yeah and not only that but my second
question is that like
like you have like i think you probably
have like this question asked many times
but i don't want to repeat it but uh
you'll have like um
republicans were like elected
republicans were against the vaccine
mandate or
any measures to like really like even
mass mandate measures
to um
mitigate the spread of the virus is it
do you think
do you think would be a good political
strategy for the democrats to say these
people these
these people like wanda scientists are
like pro covet they're they're they're
against
every measure to mitigate cope with
their pro co but they want yeah
we've talked about that a little bit
before i mean maybe you know it's really
a rhetorical trick to say that some of
these people are pro covet i don't think
it'll really catch on very much but
sometimes i'll say it it's like some
some of these people are some of the
biggest supporters of the virus that
that i've ever seen i don't know that
it's going to be any big kind of game
changer in terms of getting people to
take things seriously but you're right
it's almost like do they are they trying
to spread the virus via their policy um
but i i don't think it'll make a big
difference to adopt that as a rhetorical
trick
all right well that's pretty much what
happens today all right thank you i
appreciate the call thank you so much
great to hear from you some great great
calls this week
uh why don't we go next to
christian from california christian
you're on the air
hi david can you hear me yes i can
so i was wondering with the
big kerfuffle made this week from joe
manchin coming out and saying he will
not vote for the 3.5 trillion
infrastructure bill yeah do you think
mansion overall is is sort of bad optics
for senate democrats
well
yeah i mean so so the the complicated
thing is like of course he is
but remember that almost certainly if
mansion is replaced in virginia it's
with a republican so he does vote with
democrats on a lot of things and it gets
us back to this age-old question of
okay you primary him and he loses
but then you almost certainly end up
with a republican so yeah i can't stand
the guy
we predicted he was all of a sudden
going to be front and center in a lot of
these policy decisions i but then you
also have to understand the practicality
of west virginia and who's likely to
replace mansion and it's most most
likely going to be a republican who
supports what democrats want to do even
less the solution is less about
remove mansion because that probably
means a republican replaces him it's
we've got to win more seats back in
other states
um and also in pan with that i think we
should you know work on on moving you
know imagine constituents to the left so
that's absolutely forced to vote in a
way that you know reflects the will then
and also i would say
let's try to figure out a way for there
to be political consequences for mansion
from from being obstinate
do you think because i do tend to agree
with you that um if you know if you ran
a progressive type like aoc candidate in
west virginia that seat would probably
just go to a republican right but i mean
do you think that has more to do with
the rights framing of progressive type
democrats or i like i don't see how you
know mansion
if you were to come out aggressively for
this 3.5 trillion dollar bill how that
in any way would harm them and what
you're doing you know i completely i i
on this particular bill i totally agree
with you i think it's less about
you know i i do think that i mean the
problem would be if aoc beats mansion in
a primary aoc loses in the general that
so it's really problems that would exist
in the general i do think it's possible
for a sort of working class type guy
like for example
tim ryan from ohio who's a member of
congress he's quite
but
he has kind of like the working class
um
middle-class creds with regard to his
whole approach
that's the type of guy that if he were
to primari and he doesn't live in west
virginia this is just a hypothetical
tim ryan's someone i could see maybe
winning an election in west virginia at
the state senate level but i'm i'm not
even sure it's a tough question it's a
tough one
yeah it is all right um well thank you
so much for your time david enjoy the
rest of your day appreciate it yeah
thank you so much for the call it's a
good question important to understand
the dynamics there i mean uh very very
important all right let's speak next to
paul from c it says c-u-u what is c-u-u
paul is that a university
oh
no it's it's my airport uh
signing you know the three letters that
they give you
city airport
at which airport which airport is this
shibo mexico
mexico oh chihuahua mexico okay all
right very good all right well what's
going on paul yeah
um
i missed the call the other day i i i
was in this school and i'm musical
well i'm glad you're back
uh i don't know i mean if i had a
specific question it would be like
uh my mom got vaccinated in the u.s okay
she's over there right now
then
she took a flight like two two weeks ago
three weeks ago
she has her vaccination car and all that
and all that stuff but they
they
still require recovery test
she thought once she was vaccinated they
um
at the airport she would be asked to
[Music]
to show her vaccination card hold on a
second let's back up well let's can we
back up one second paul
yeah so yeah when she came to the united
states she was not yet vaccinated is
that correct
um oh okay okay yeah she went to she
went twice uh she was
she went in like march
april something like that
she got vaccinated she got back and she
went back okay i got it yeah the u.s
requires a negative test to come in this
is for americans and foreigners i just
came back from spain i'm vaccinated i
needed a negative test to come to the
u.s so that applies to everybody right
now
hey and
it's crazy because i can go to the us
and get vaccinated and
and i i got thinking about this like
uh when when they
when they when talking about the fake
vaccination cards
uh you covered it
took your cars and talked about it yeah
uh do you think it's affecting the
numbers now the the false vaccination
cards and now
uh foreigners going there
to get vaccinated like do you think that
throws off like
uh the shots of how many americans have
been vaccinated i think it throws it off
slightly but i don't think it's enough
of a to make any significant difference
you have to remember
every one percent of the u.s is 3.3
million people
so half a percent is
1.65 million people and a quarter of a
percent represents 800 000 people so the
number of people that would have to do
it to really make any substantive
difference uh is is huge so i you're
you're right on some level it throws it
off but i think we have a pretty good
sense of how many americans have been
vaccinated
okay yeah i just have like one
last question if i can sure
like
if they pass an infrastructure plan
and it goes through these red areas when
people don't want to leave
the work they do for the company or
fracking company or something like that
to go join
the clean energy
do you think that you
in the u.s will be open to
to hiring foreign
foreign people oh you're saying if in
red states a lot of the people
don't want to go and get jobs for green
energy will then will the companies look
to foreign workers
yeah you think you can get a work visa
oh
that's an you would have to talk to an
immigrant i have no idea but i can tell
you for sure
that if companies have trouble finding
people
they will go wherever they need to in
order to find people to do work that's
for people i think they're going to find
resistance with people not wanting the
the good paying jobs
i think 99 of these right wingers who
love oil
if uh the job opportunity is to be a
solar panel installer and it pays 25
bucks an hour i think they're going to
go and get the job i think it's that
simple
well i actually might think
well thank you david okay thanks paul
great to hear from you paul from
chihuahua
mexico that does it for calls today i'll
speak to everybody again very soon
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon
go to patreon.com davidpakmanshow where
you can get access to behind the scenes
videos the daily bonus show the
commercial free daily show as well as
special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpakmanshow alright
let's get right into your emails you can
email us info davidpakman.com
every friday we take a look through the
mailbag so to speak it's really more of
an internet folder but it still seems
like we call it a mailbag i don't know
why it doesn't make any sense um and
emails of all sorts are featured you can
email info davidpakman.com with your
thoughts about the show politics
questions whatever the case may be
so many meaty and substantive emails
this week let's start
one email
from one of our viewers
who is a neurologist making a very
important point
last week you had a caller that
mentioned nurses talking about how the
covet vaccine might cause individuals to
misinterpret their symptoms it seems
this discussion of the nurses might be a
misinterpretation of an actual report
there is a report that there are quote
functional neurological disorders after
the vaccine i am a neurologist
functional neurological disorder is the
medical term for what used to be called
psychogenic symptoms in other words
folks are reporting symptoms that are
not of medical origin after their
vaccines below is a summary of the
report from medscape happy to interpret
but as a brief summary there are a
number of neurological examination
tricks that neurologists use to identify
psychogenic versus neurological weakness
one of these is the hoover sign
mentioned below yeah so this this is a
really important thing
a lot of the time
people will not understand
the difference between a symptom
and
an actual physiological side effect of a
medication
and
for example
you can have
a headache after a vaccine or after a
medication or after working out or
whatever
it's not that the headache isn't real
but there may not be
a physiological cause for that
but it doesn't make the symptom any less
real and there's a lot of different
terms that are sometimes applied here in
different disciplines sometimes people
talk about psychosomatic we don't even
need to go into that as our viewer here
is saying we're talking about when we
say functional neurological disorder if
you don't know what that means you're
like whoa that's a the vaccine causes a
functional neurological disorder as is
being pointed out that means there's a
symptom
which we don't believe to actually be
caused
by something going on neurologically and
this applies in many other areas of
medicine as well very important point
and you can read more about it if that's
interesting to you next email comes from
cody
cody says hello david i'm having trouble
dealing with the fact that some members
of my family have stated they will never
get the vaccine especially my brother
who's a local business owner and comes
into contact with a good deal of our
community i've presented them with the
information on the vaccine how it's fda
approved
how 99 of deaths and 97 of
hospitalizations are from the
unvaccinated and info on mrna vaccines
and nothing is getting through to them i
often get the rebuttal that it's my body
my choice but when i explain it isn't
just them they are affecting it's
everyone around them
friends family in our community they
shrug it off and suggest those people
should stay at home then
do you have any suggestions on a
different approach to this i appreciate
your time and enjoy your content keep up
the good work listen i am not pretending
to have solutions here uh sometimes
knowing someone who gets very sick or
dies
is the only thing that will change the
minds of some of these people even then
sometimes that won't change their minds
so i don't have advice sadly other than
advice for you which is at a certain
point you might decide for your own
sanity this is a personal decision that
you've had enough
and you're not going to try to convince
them anymore but maybe you decide you
can't have them in your lives that's not
a suggestion and i've not decided that
with anybody
but
you might reach a point where you say
this is too much the stress of this is
too much
and for safety and sanity i'm opting out
of this relationship or you might say
i'm just going to try to keep going
because it's so important to me
or you might try a different approach i
don't know i wish i had an answer about
what the right way to convince these
people what the most effective way would
be
to convince these folks
next email today is from michael
michael says hi i watch the show from
the uk most days find them entertaining
and informative nevertheless i cringed
oh no
i cringed during an article when you
repeatedly said a covet number that had
tripled had increased by 300 percent
tripling means an increase of 200
percent just this doubling would be a
100 increase careful with the maths
and keep up the good work
i cringed when i realized i made this
mathematical mistake
i make every effort to be accurate and
precise with the audience
i appreciate the correction from michael
and when i said the other day coveted
cases are up 300 percent and deaths are
up 70 percent
300 percent is a
quadrupling whereas the 70 increase in
deaths is almost a doubling okay
apologies
and always appreciate the corrections
skye wrote in
sky says david
my in-laws are both major trump
supporters
as well as deep into conspiracies my
husband and his mother regularly have
debates and recently had one that took
an interesting turn they were talking
about vaccines and in his desperation to
get her to see reason he suggested that
all the misinformation was a liberal
conspiracy to eliminate all the
anti-vaxx conservatives in order to win
elections he also posed the question of
how many liberals have died due to covid
and asked her to name one she could not
i found this strategy interesting and
thought you might as well
do do we have to sink so low as to
basically trick anti-vaxxers into
getting the vaccine at this point would
it be effective or damaging in the long
term i've talked about this before
i think that
there would be
i don't know if we would call them scams
there would be things joe biden could
say and do
that would make the right go and get
vaccinated for example imagine if joe
biden announced like of course he would
never do it it would never be legal
but imagine if joe biden announced
because of all of the things that these
red state governors are doing
after october 1st conservatives and
republicans will no longer be allowed to
get the vaccine it's like it's so
obviously impossible legally and
logistic like it would never happen but
the point is
i am convinced
that if trumpists conservatives
republicans whoever is in the anti-vax
group
if they came to believe
that they were not going to be allowed
to get the vaccine because of their
political views
millions of them would run out
and get the vaccine there's no question
about it if a theory hypothesis rumor
started to spread
that the left doesn't want conservatives
to get vaccinated
so that they die
i think there is no doubt that if it was
believed if it was believed of course if
it was believed
that a ton of these right wingers would
go out and try to get vaccinated now is
it damaging in the long term yeah i mean
if if if joe biden did something like
that even if it worked i do think in the
long term it would be damaging because
it would further foment the idea that
the government is lying to you and you
can't trust the government to do
anything and on and on and on so i'm not
recommending it i don't think it would
be a good long-term play
but it would sure as hell work uh with
some of these uh some some of these
right-wingers so interesting that the
conversation went that way
spencer wrote to me
spencer said i am seeing studies
suggesting that teenage boys are far
more likely to suffer from myocarditis
related to the vaccine than to end up in
the hospital from covet have you heard
anything backing this claim up i'm only
able to find a few articles talking
about it yeah i read a study this
morning about it it's not true
um in fact there there was a study that
was going to look at myocarditis in
teenage boys
and it had like a sample of nine million
vaccinated teenage boys
and like none of them got it
or or at least none of them got it badly
enough to have to be hospitalized or
something like that uh no the the
evidence i've seen is that um the
vaccine is safer than kovid at every age
group at every age group very important
because there are some who will say
if you are of a certain age it actually
makes less sense to get the vaccine
but from what i've seen is that at every
age group for just about every medical
condition
you are better off with the vaccine and
its possible side effects than you are
getting covered big picture
statistically speaking
lastly today this one's a doozy guys
this is from jj
this stuff is constantly coming into my
email it's just dumping in all the time
here is someone who has
somehow ended up believing really
incorrect things about covid and
vaccination
jj says david sir no they didn't say sir
how about the adults unable to get the
real vaccines
also
the delta virus thing a complete lie
covid sext when and how
no mutations right there
the proof needed
it's so sad
that this is going on in our country
i i don't know what else to say you know
how about the adults unable to get the
real vaccines i think this is
some some allusion to fake vaccines i
don't i don't know
the delta virus thing is a complete lie
um you know we we sequence the virus we
know what percentage of cases are delta
we saw mew peaked in july and then has
come down at some point if if someone's
gonna say
this is an apple and you're gonna say
it's not an apple it's a fake apple and
it's imaginary
at some point you can't convince them
covet sext
i don't know or do viruses have have sex
i did i didn't think so i don't maybe
they do i don't think it matters
um
incoherent and unfortunately really
really unfortunately
a lot of people i don't even know what
that belief i don't even know what
they're saying but i know a lot of
people believe stuff like that
because they email me all the time we're
gonna have real trouble getting out of
this pandemic
if that type of stuff
remains as prevalent as it is we'll
track whether vaccinations go up with
the latest requirements and initiatives
from joe biden we will track all of it
we've got a great bonus show for you
today please become a member really
folks please become a member sign up at
joinpackman.com
we do this show every day
but then we do an extra show called the
bonus show every day
and you can get instant access to it if
you become a member at joinpackman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman